foreign
although this program was made in 1982
the information contained in it was
never presented on the regular media
it was in fact the new york times in a
story in january who disclosed the first
part of the story which was that the
green berets eight of them were present
during a torture session and the member
of the salvadoran army
who talked about this who is now
deserted and was living in mexico
uh he was somewhat intimidated i guess
by talking to the new york times and
he's later
revealed to these to mexican media and
that's the transcript in this store in
this article that the
special forces and i should say the u.s
special forces was created originally by
the cia
the special forces were actually
involved in the torture as opposed to
standing by observing it the training
facilities
for
torture for interrogation techniques
were in san antonio texas at one time
it troubles me
not
obviously because i was once part of all
this but also
just as an american citizen to realize
that this country is indulging
in activities that are just as cruel
and just as as depraved in some cases
and almost as extensive as what for
example the
the gestapo indulged in in germany
we haven't uh liquidated
5 million jews
but 800 000 minimum figure people killed
in terrorist circumstances in the third
world is a lot of people dead
former cia official john stockwell and
co-editor of covert action information
bulletin lewis wolf
tonight
on alternative views
[Music]
hey
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight on part two of covert action
part two of a three-part series we again
feature lewis wolfe editor of covert
action information bulletin and john
stockwell former cia official and author
of in search of enemies and red sunset
we'll take you on a tour of covert
intelligence activity around the world
some by the cia
some by other countries and even
an attempted coup by the ku klux klan
now some news we have something on the
fbi it seems like they're
trying to climb back in our
bedrooms and telephones and everywhere
else all of our
organizations that we have
back in april 28th
there was the upi story which
quoted the
fbi director william webster saying
folks we have some new
fbi guidelines and that means we're
going to be able to
go into the political spying business
again but he says don't worry about it
our agents uh only will be doing it if
we think that a crime is going to be
committed
there were some pretty
uh stringent
uh
guidelines laid down on the fbi back
during the ford administration as a
result of the
revelations of the cointelpro program
from 1957 to 1951 and 71. amazingly
enough i gave a presentation to the
college class these are college graduate
students they didn't know what the
cointelpro program was i thought my god
is our memory that short so to let you
know what cointelpro was it was j edgar
hoover's program to
infiltrate dislocate disrupt any lawful
political organizations which j edgar
hoover didn't like
they had wiretaps bugs surreptitious
mail openings break-ins
they
sent anonymous letters and all to break
up marriages they disrupted meetings
ostracized people from their professions
got people fired from their jobs they
provoked target groups into rivalries
that could result in death
they dynamited the
publishing places of the dissident press
organizations
and are
from our program on the clan we found
out that the clan had organized over 40
chapters of the clan in north carolina
alone back in the 60s anyway it was a
terrible terrible thing and
but they're wanting to do again but
supposedly more gently but in the
june 83 edition of the inquiry magazine
the libertarian magazine
matt hentoff says watch out folks the
interpretation which william webster
gives on what they can do is much more
broad
than even tail gunner joe mccarthy had
in his heyday
and the new guidelines
give to the agents to let them go on
their feelings as to what
may advocate only advocate what they
consider to be criminal activity and
that could be most anything
and as the
as the article uh ends it says
if keeping tabs on mere public advocacy
is an authorized law informant activity
law enforcement activity in the domestic
security field
then between what the fbi hears from
soap boxes and informants and learns
from collectively signs assigned ads and
letters to newspaper editors
folks
get ready for another cointelpro program
as an example of the sort of thing that
the fbi has been doing over the last
several decades in the subversive groups
that they've been infiltrating and
harassing one case is the national
lawyers guild
they've recently put a multi-million
dollar lawsuit through the courts
claiming that the fbi has been illegally
harassing them surveilling them
infiltrating their group since the 1940s
and during this lawsuit a document came
out that revealed that an fbi informer
within the national lawyers guild bar
association has every year been leaking
to the fbi a list of all of the names of
the members of the national lawyers
guild that the fbi has put into its
files to keep information on and to
surveil and they've also the national
lawyers guild has uncovered over 400 000
pages of documents that the fbi had
amassed on them that are in fbi files
showing the depth of the surveillance of
the fbi on the national lawyers guild
and they claim that another three
million pages of documents have also
been amassed by the fbi that the fbi has
refused so far to release but that
freedom of information suits are trying
to get opened up and disclosed so here's
an example of the kinds of groups that
the fbi claim you have to have to keep
their eye on the national lawyers guild
this very subversive organization of
liberal lawyers
there's in this article in inquiry it
says that not only will the new
guidelines allow the fbi to continue
investigations
into organizations but it can do it even
when an organization is inactive like if
the international workers of the world
the oiw wobblies if they wanted to get
organized again the fbi would be there
be one of the first ones to join up to
to continue their surveillance of them
even if there is no immediate harm
there's a guideline even if there is no
immediate harm from the organization and
there's another thing that is continuing
to that we still have which their media
don't talk about
and that is the concentration camps in
the united states we have concentration
camps i think what there are six or
eight of them around the country that
are caretaker status and any time the
president says there is a national
emergency the fbi trots out its files
and says okay we'll put these people in
these concentration camps
that's on the law and they're just ready
and waiting
i have one final piece of data on this
national lawyer's guild suit and that is
the fbi itself has confirmed that at
least 13 guild members were undercover
fbi agents and 102 more were paid
informants this shows the extent to
which the fbi has infiltrated even
liberal groups like the f the national
lawyers guild and has also subverted or
corrupted their members by making them
paid informants of the fbi so this just
shows you that any group can be
infiltrated and surveilled by the fbi
and on these lists of people to be put
in concentration camps in the event of
so-called national emergency are people
like
a good friend john duncan i imagine from
the civil liberties union civil
liberties union folks are on the fbi's
list people like
oh jane fonda dr spock dear dr spock
is on the list so
we might have pretty good time that
concentration camp don't you expect that
we'll be there yeah
i was a member of sds back in the 60s
and i'll tell you what there never was a
more boring organization
i went to about two meetings and they
sat around argued about semantics and
this and that and finally this one
radical guy had real frizzy hair and
just kind of a crazy dude he was
advocating taking over mcdonald's taking
over this taking over that
one of the meetings he finally talked us
in we went down and occupied the
mcdonald's
and after after a while i got to
thinking boy this is pretty stupid
and i'd always been
an advocate of freedom of milkshake so i
ended up buying a strawberry milkshake
and going home and that was the extent
of my involvement with sds
but i'm sure it's in a file somewhere
and that guy who that who provoked
everybody doing it more than likely was
an fbi agent it was obvious because he
was so blatant about it they found that
uh in previous programs we've had on
civil liberties they found that the
fellow who triggered the chicago riot by
skinning up but climbing up the uh
um
oh not a ladder what do you call those
things in the parks where the pigeons
fly jump on the maple or without you
statues that's it anyway this guy
climbed up on the statue and and uh
fluttered a vietcong flag up there and
that triggered the police then another
another person went up and slapped a
policeman in the face both of these guys
even though they had beards and long
hair were both police undercover people
and they were provocative agents and
other people i've talked to said their
organizations had these
provocateurs in them who turned out to
be
fbi
agents
what else you got craig
well let me see i clipped a little thing
out of the paper i think it was the
awesome paper i neglected to mark it
careless me
this is a direct quote i wonder if you
could guess who said this
i quote
every gun that is made every warship
launched
every rocket fired signifies in the
final sense a theft from those who
hunger and are not fed
those who are cold and are not clothed
this world in arms is not spending money
alone
it is spending the sweat of its laborers
the genius of its scientists the hopes
of its children
this is not a way of life at all in any
true sense
under the cloud of war it is humanity
hanging on a cross of iron
you guys have any idea who said that he
also said as part of that every warship
launched every gun that is fired every
bomb that is dropped represents a theft
a theft from those people who are hungry
and don't have enough clothes and don't
have work you obviously know who it is
who do you think stokely carmichael
no that was dwight david eisenhower that
subversive president we had yes indeed
and he was a republican i may note and
the commander of allied forces in europe
during the war
so you might think he would know
something about that
and now the second in a three-part
series on covert action with john
stockwell and louis wolf
john there has been over the last few
years also a small handful of
journalists who have been sort of cia
watchdogs most prominent of which has
been lewis wolff we have an interview
with him maybe you can to introduce this
interview tell us a little bit about
lewis wolff and his journalistic
publications who is lewis and what has
he been doing over the years and why is
the government so outraged by him
well his background is is
it's thoroughly uh
legitimate standard if you will
journalism he was assigned for a couple
of years in manchester
writing for a couple of prominent news
organizations manchester england yes
manchester england
and uh eventually made his way
through london
back to the united states where he
gravitated
to
a scrutiny of the cia and the
intelligence community watching the
revelations of the church committee
information that he had come across in
his research some of which he had
published
as part of news stories previously other
parts of which he was not permitted to
publish by the nature of the press
establishment
and so he
put together with bill schapp and ellen
ray the covert action information
bulletin whose function was to focus on
the intelligence organizations of the
united states and discuss
and expose in a perfectly legitimate way
the covert action
activities of the cia principally as
well as the other intelligence
organizations
i believe they formed that in about 1976
and have been in washington since
publishing stories of true stories their
quality their standards of journalism
are exceedingly high
that bulletin is distributed in the
state department and it's sold out the
first morning that it's put on the
stands in the state department news
stands they also publish in that
bulletin the names of ci agents and
where they are now as they're assigned
and reassigned about the world
i believe that in very recent months
they have ceased the policy of
publishing
names because the controversy is so hot
and they would just assume
and and also it's never been their
intention to break the law they've made
that clear from the outset
bill shap is the brother he is a
highly competent attorney
and is the brother of a top sportscaster
in new york city
he is a very articulate man himself and
has testified to the senate many times
against the names of agents bill for
example and and
defending what he and lou wilford doing
and
after his testimony many times senators
have come up and shaken his hand and
said i disagree with you but you
certainly make your case for the
legitimacy of what you're doing very
well
let's let's yeah let's take a look at uh
some of the things which lewis wolff had
to say and we'll
let you comment every so often on
greatness okay
what in the years that you've been
publishing it you think are some of your
most significant revelations are there
some stories that even shocked you well
i think one of the big stories that we
were able to document in some detail was
the
the
whole scope of cia activities similar to
what the cia did in chile and which was
documented by the senate select
committee
was the
whole covert action program in jamaica
in between 1976 and 1980
and we were we did a great deal of
research into that and we discovered
many in many ways a very similar program
almost a classic
model that was followed along the lines
of what they did in chile
including three major categories
military paramilitary activity
the use of propaganda in the in the
media
and the third one which was economic
warfare using the multilateral
organizations the
international monetary fund and others
to withhold loans which had been
promised to the jamaican government
this is one example what are a couple
more of the details of that you
particularly mentioned those first
two examples of actual paramilitary
activity well cia was involved in
jamaica
there was a fire for example that took
place in jamaica of an old people's home
i think 150
old and infirmed women many of them
blind
were living in this home and
as it turned out the place burned down
in the space of about eight minutes
seven or eight minutes
it was discovered that the phone wires
had been cut
and that
their exits had all been blocked even
those who could see their way out could
not get out
and
that the
means by which the fire was set was the
use of a petroleum jelly which was
unavailable in jamaica
this was one indication among others
that there was outside help
why would this why would the cia you
might ask why would the cia want to
murder 150 old women
it was because it was an effort part of
a very large-scale effort to discredit
the government in jamaica which was at
the time
headed by michael manley the prime
minister
there were
images produced of michael manley
in the
media in the daily gleaner which was the
newspaper which the united states
through the cia helped to
support and there is a good deal of
evidence of that there were images of
michael manley showing a death mask i
mean it was his face which had been
somehow made to look like a death mask
although it was pretending to be a
photograph of him
and there were many
ways to try and discredit him this is
very very similar in fact to what the
cia did to try and discredit salvador
allende in chile if you remember
richard nixon instructed the cia in a
meeting uh
which was in 1970 in the white house
and there was a document in the senate
com report which is reprinted and he
said make the economy scream
those were his words and that's of
course what the cia proceeded to do in
chile and that's what
they also did in jamaica they also
furnished
a lot of munitions and assistance to the
terrorist squads that were going around
killing people in the in the cities and
also in the countryside in jamaica as
well that's correct
well john you had a trip down to jamaica
and you saw a lot of these things about
jamaica
with your own eyes right
yes indeed
a very moving a very interesting trip to
me
to see
a target country
at a time
in the height of a ci operation when i
was completely outside
so there's no way that i could see to
see the problem that journalists have
always had when the us government was
targeting on a country in a situation
trying to destabilize it overthrow or
manipulate the elections or whatever
of trying to figure out what's going on
when you don't
have access to all of the flow of cables
and the discussions and national
security council meetings and whatnot
for the planning
i observed that from published
information the cia station there was
quite large for that size of the country
it was huge in fact it was
bigger than any station i knew of in
africa although jamaica was a fairly
small island with 2 million people
that's typical of when the ci is got a
big operation going into place they beef
up the station and beef up the offices
back stateside
the tone and flow of
articles in the gleaner was of course as
loose says
definitely a chapter out of chile or a
chapter out of the angular operation
every indication of a massive ci
operation going to destabilize the
government to make the economy scream
and uh in that case
i would say that uh probably someone got
promoted for that one probably several
people because manly was run out of
because it worked by a legitimate yeah
without without a scandal without an
assassination without uh
the things that have caused the cia so
much grief
uh
manly a champion of
of social democracy of of giving the
people a piece of the pie
was thrown out of office and an arch
capitalist
was put in office
and
again there was
minimal adverse publicity
lou wolf and the others were
studying the situation and did publish
about what was going on but it was not
published in the new york times in the
washington post and the big
the big television networks didn't do
studies on it primarily because even if
the journalists
of the big organs knew what was
happening and might have wanted to
they really just because of the secrecy
couldn't get the truth about what the
united states was doing
one interesting thing was that
the effectiveness of the lies the liars
in our government you know the duplicity
when we formed the cia
we committed our leaders to having two
policies as loose as the rhetoric the
public statements and the truth about
what united states policy is
so an interesting measure
of of presidents is how effectively they
lie interesting discussions that occur
inside the cia is about
lying would would you lie you know
you're the ddo and you're going to
testify to the senate and serious
discussions are you going to lie because
if you do it's perjury and there's a
chance you could go to jail and yet you
know the organization expects you to lie
president carter was one of the most
effective liars i have ever watched on
television and through the media as a
poker player man i would never go up
against that man he could look at that
camera and
say things
that obviously he knew were completely
and totally false
and i would study his expression and i
could detect
nothing except occasionally
a little wisp of a smile
that wasn't consistent with what he was
saying
like he thought it was funny but one of
his more classic tech actually
well the the the smile that i was
referring to wasn't that it was just a
kind of like he was repressing a grin
like he thought it was funny how he
rationalized these things i don't know
but one of his most
uh of conspicuous lies was when he sat
down with manly just a few weeks before
the elections
in washington and told him face to face
that the ci don't have the cia doing
anything to destabilize you or your
government we have no such program going
when obviously he did
and
he pulled it off to the point where even
manly was troubled very effective lie
liars
another major story that we
we uncovered was the whole range of
cia media operations
throughout the world we did an analysis
of these operations and the use of
money very large scale money is thought
between
one third and and forty percent of the
cia's budget and i should say that that
budget figure is the biggest secret that
there is in washington today
at that time it was estimated that the
1978 budget was in the range of one and
a half billion dollars
a more recent estimate by a
military journal
not a
liberal journal by any means estimated
that the cia's budget today is in the
range of 10 billion dollars
at any rate
this analysis that we made of the cia's
media operations disclosed among other
things that they deliver
through cia couriers
ready to print or ready to broadcast
news and i put that in inverted commas
which is
used by the media
and this is created by the cia
how often does the cia manipulate the
media in this way plant stories get
their views in the media is this fairly
common as a modus operandi for the cia
it goes beyond your
in the in the course of the past 30
years it goes beyond your
wildest imagination the extent to which
the ci has gone to manipulate public
opinion
if you include the mh chaos program
which was a billion dollar program
of setting up proprietary companies
setting up student organizations so they
could draw radical students in
and do every kind of of duplicious
manipulation of
of national student movements press
propaganda labor extensive formation of
labor unions funding of major labor
unions with the objective essentially of
manipulating the mind and attitudes of
workers throughout the nation and the
world
this was the essential tool that they
used to destabilize chile and overthrow
allende was of course making the economy
scream getting to the military officers
but it was essentially the truckers
union that finally brought the country
down
and justified quote justified pinochet
j's takeover of power
five thousand university professors
they've co-opted this is church
committee revelations i'm not making
this up it's in print church committee's
revelations 5 000 university professors
co-opted to help the cia manipulate
people's minds 400 journalists in the
u.s including big-name journalists now
that's a big chunk of the prominent
journalist co-opted to function
routinely
to put help the ci put out the stories
and biases to the world there are a
whole range of
of areas wherein the cia provides
briefings to selected journalists and
there are
numerous cases where the cia has for
example published
books and several thousand books were
published in english by by the cia and
this is documented in the church
committee report they set up 250 new
services and wire services some of which
not all but some of which are still
in the pocket of the cia
and i think it's only fair to to say
that uh
even some journalists who don't realize
there are some who are winning but there
are also some who do not realize that
they're being
targeted by the cia
when they come home from a trip overseas
they might talk to somebody and they
don't realize
at least right away who they're talking
to and then it turns out that they've
been the source of information which was
used by the cie
and then specific operations
around the world from corner to corner
to discredit this individual create an
impression about that situation such as
el salvador the famous white papers in
the angolan operation
which i i note were you know back in the
back in the good old days we did a
better job our our white papers in the
angolan operation were based on very
specific photographs and heart
information of soviet ships putting into
puerto ambrim and angola
the white paper that the cia produced
for alexander haig to justify the
intervention in el salvador
was a piece of trash it was discredited
by the right and the left and the center
it didn't hold together
i should point for example to the
the stories that came out during the
angola operation where it was discovered
that
the cia is involved in a massive covert
operation which the congress
cut off when they learned about it
there were certainly a small handful
really a tiny handful you could count
them on the fingers of one hand of the
members of congress who knew about that
operation
and the scale of it
beforehand and then they cut it off well
one of the revelations at the time that
came out was that the cia had
uh
created a story that was planted in the
media that the cubans who were in angola
at the time were raping angolan women
and that they were
really doing very very gross things to
these women and killing them
well it was disclosed in fact by john
stockwell among other people who was the
former cia
station chief or in charge of the cia's
task force in angola
that that whole story was created by the
cia station in zambia
and in
in zaire
where they sat around a table and wrote
this story and then it was fed to a
a stringer who then fed it to a new
service who then got it to the ap
associated press who then picked it up
and was sent around the world and was
printed in hundreds of newspapers as
fact
but you can rest assured
that
it it is at least very difficult for the
american people including us
to know what is true about the
sandinista government in nicaragua for
example or about el salvador or about
argentina and the falklands right now
our former ally of a month ago is now
our enemy in this confrontation
in jamaica
for example and then this this very
uh specific
uh the the libyan hit squad
the not the mythical libyan hit squad we
had a situation where reagan and
president reagan and president gadhafi
were
confronting each other
internationally
reagan ordered our ship into what libya
claims as its waters with the specific
intention of of either standing qaddafi
down or provoking an incident and it
worked he shot down two libyan jet
fighter planes
and then gaddafi was incensed and there
was a credibility problem there was the
president of the giant united states
confronting this relatively small arab
country
i guess this leads us to your covert
action information bulletin
because there's a story in here about
the hit squads and it actually
originated apparently
with the
israeli secret police the mossad
it's a very interesting case study of
how
these propaganda operations can come
about
apparently since
the israelis working as they have for
many years very closely the the israeli
secret intelligence service or mossad
has worked very very closely with the
cia and in fact the cia helped to set it
up back in the in the mid 50s originally
part of the story came from mossad that
there were two
people who apparently were
either employed or were agents contract
agents for mossad who fed some of this
information to the u.s government i see
and the u.s government was fully
prepared to believe it
they said that one of their witnesses or
one of their sources had been
polygraphed and had checked out his
information had checked out there was a
story suggesting that
it was reported by one of the networks
that
somebody had been offered a quarter of a
million dollars for his information
to the effect that there were hit squads
and some of it originated as i said from
mossad and some of it originated from
cia
fabrications jack anderson for example
reported that some of the information
that he had been given and reported in
his column had turned out to have been
cia fabrications
it's important to remember that the
israelis as much i guess as the u.s
considers it a priority to discredit and
to
possibly destabilize or overthrow the
libyan government
and
one method that they saw thought of i
guess was to create a story that said
that libya had sent death squads to
assassinate president reagan and other
high officials
go ahead well only recently uh
some of the same high officials who
before were saying that
there were that they had evidence that
some of these hit squads had entered the
country through canada are now on record
and quoted in newsweek and other media
saying that they never
located a single
person and a single
single evidence that there was
a hit squad and yet they say there is
still a threat
well um
i think it's fair to assume though there
is not enough information yet to say but
it's fair to assume that the cia was
hoping through this to create a
justification for further intervention
in in libya possible
military activity or economic boycott as
our blockade as they've now proposed as
has been proposed by the white house
well let's take a look at some of the
articles in the latest issue of the
covert action information bulletin not
only will it give you an idea of what
the magazine is about it's sir oh my
goodness over 50 pages but also it gives
just this one issue gives a good example
of the widespread operations not only of
the cia it's not just restricted to the
cia but mercenary activities around the
world as
well we have been following the sachel
island
attempted coup for ever since it started
and we did a program with john stockwell
just recently where we mentioned that i
noticed um page four you have an article
that says sheld beat back the
mercenaries this is quite a complex
operation which involves south africa
and mercenaries and the french was the
cia involved in that
there's still a lot of information that
will come out but
it is known that the
some of the activity
i i should say primarily the main
source of the coup or attempted coup was
south africa
that south african intelligence
including one admitted former so-called
former
member of the south african intelligence
corps
who says that he quote unquote retired
in order to go for a visit to the
seychelles
for
his vacation
[Music]
and largely the the the program was
initiated by the by the south africans
it does appear however that the united
states which has had an ongoing interest
in creating a base of operations in the
indian ocean
and the seychelles is is a very
strategic area not just because of its
it has no large
natural resources as such but that it is
a critical importance to
to the u.s as a jumping point in in in
the indian ocean it looks like there are
other aspects too that they're also
trying to keep the government of
mauritius from becoming a more
progressive government there were some
significant elections coming up plus
there was something i didn't know at all
and that was the fact that there is an
island chained commodores which actually
were taken over in a coup which was
carried out by mercenaries yes
that in that case it was largely french
intelligence which was the source of
that one
there is some indication that the cia
was
involved though somewhat peripherally in
that one so i can see where that could
stimulate people like in the
the group down in new orleans of
missionary of missionaries boy they are
in a way aren't they
mercenaries that we're going to take
over dominica
yes
since the apparently the plot fell
through for grenada
and they've seen that it can't happen in
comoros that they actually can take over
an island government and run it the the
case of the attempted coup in dominica
is a very interesting one and here the
u.s involvement is
rather rather
strong
there was an attempt to build a force
mainly made up of members of the ku klux
klan
together with some other former
and active mercenaries who had
long involvement in
u.s special forces and army
background and
they at first
their first idea was to invade grenada
but then they realized that the
grenadine government probably would be
able to
to
offset their activities and and probably
defeat them and since their security
forces are quite well
organized there and so they changed
their plan and and decided to go into
dominica the former prime minister
patrick john who was very very closely
identified with south africa in fact he
had helped to set up a monitoring
station and also a base for
the manufacture of long-range
torpedoes which could be built
with the help of south africa on in
which he helped to set up
and basically
they had hoped he had hoped that if they
if the coup succeeded and he agreed with
the clan people
that if
succeeded that he would give them
rights to casinos to gambling operations
to he would even give them several posts
in his cabinet if he came back to power
well of course needless to say it failed
but see was there some dopes um some
narcotics business exactly
this is there often is in these things
this is on page 44 by the way we're
getting a little bit ahead of you this
is also covered in the same uh
in the same yes this highlights a point
though that we've made several times on
this show how the cia will use anyone to
carry through their objectives the ku
klux klan mercenaries the mafia drug
operations it's reasons like this that
john stockwell thinks that the cia is
completely corrupt an immoral
operation not to mention the 800 000
people that have been killed through cia
operations i think 800 000 is a very
very conservative figure but yes that's
that's uh correct
uh there is clearly a trend today in the
cia to
to move more in the direction of
contracting out some of the operations
that it does not really want to get
itself not that it doesn't want to get
involved but doesn't want to get caught
with his pants down doing it and so some
of the more sensitive activities they're
branching out and letting other either
other intelligence services or other
quote unquote private freelance types
it looks like
that they are developing a very
significant alliance with the south
africans and the argentinas once again
these
are both covered in this edition of the
covert action information bulletin
angola the pretoria's continuing war
talks about the south african
involvement there mozambique rebels
exposed once again
we find south africa involved in that
and the cia in that case yeah and the
cia and then
we get to an article here about
argentina activates international death
squads and this
article shows that these
god wretched horrible people in involved
in a tremendous amount of torture and
maiming and killing of people in
argentina are now like say their
subcontractees
and not only that but the u.s is trying
to make
a regional type of kind of a nato it's
called saito which is a good saint over
saido sado
but anyway with south africa taking care
of the area in the indian ocean and
africa and argentina taking care of
central america and south america in
fact argentina said they would be glad
to come up and help
with the el salvadorian folks right
that's correct
argentina if there's a country in the
world that has perfected the art of
torture and the art of making people
disappear it is argentina
and thousands upon thousands of
argentinians
have
have disappeared and
i think that this article demonstrates
and this was an article which we did a
lot of research on and which was the
result of a lot of press reports which
came out in some of them in south africa
itself
of the fact that the sea that the
argentinians had
sent some of their more renowned and
best-known torturers
to south africa because they could no
longer
be active in argentina they were so well
known so they sent them to south africa
as part of the diplomatic corps in the
argentine embassy they were special in
torture
yes
go ahead it is unclear at this point
whether they were advising the south
africans who also know a good deal about
how to torture people and how them
how to
make people die in prison as they have
the highest
rate of
death of people in in their prisons
whether in fact they're training each
other is unclear but certainly they have
a good deal of of
sharing and common interests involved we
showed the movie on company business
which you or sections of the movie on
company business which you might
remember
this movie showed the
complicity of the
cia with torture all around the world as
a matter of fact there are cia torture
schools in the united states they bring
people over here from various countries
abroad police military
teach them the very sophisticated ways
of torture then they go back and operate
on their own folks back home
and just to make sure that everything
goes right the cia then has their agents
which go down and supervise they hold
clinics they bring people off the
streets and torture them i mean it
sounds like something which
you couldn't even think up out of a sick
imagination but this is what goes on
and the next article in your bulletin
for march talks about the salvadorian
deserter who disclosed the green beret
torture role this was in the news just
recently and it has actually the
transcript and the considerable summary
of what actually went on it showed the
americans supervising and helping out
and they tortured the first person to
show that uh
house be done this is a 14 year old boy
and the next person brought in was a 13
year old girl of course after raping her
then they let the el salvadorians try it
and make sure they did it right it's
it's a gruesome story and i think this
is an example of
uh
something that the american people are
being asked to overlook or to
turn the blind eye to that is the
brutality of the salvadoran government
it is not a case of
salvadoran of
president duarte
as quote unquote a moderate person who
is trying to stand up to the forces both
from left and right which the new york
times always says exactly it was in fact
the new york times in a story in january
who disclosed the first part of the
story which was that the green berets
eight of them were present during a
torture session and it was a major story
strangely it was
such a major story but it was on page
two of the new york times rather than on
page one but it was a very big and
important story i would say however
that
one of the reasons i guessed was that
the the salvadoran the member of the
salvadoran army
who talked about this who is now
deserted and was living in mexico
he was somewhat intimidated i guess by
talking to the new york times and he's
later
revealed to the to mexican media and
that's the transcript in this store in
this article that the
special forces and i should say the u.s
special forces was created originally by
the cia
the special forces were actually
involved in the torture as opposed to
standing by observing it they said they
didn't rape the little girl though i
mean there is some morality
right louis how does this torture and
all of these cia covert operations fit
into american foreign policy as a whole
you have a couple articles in your
current journal about the role of the
cia and these sorts of operations we're
talking about within american foreign
policy could you focus on that for a
minute
well i guess it comes down to the the
whole
doctrine that the united states feels
it has to
keep its
role in its fear of influence or spheres
of influence
and part of this is
putting governments in power and part of
it is keeping them in power
now there are many governments with whom
the united states has been closely
identified around the country
who cannot stay in power without massive
repression
and
of course el salvador is one there are
many others around the world in all the
three continents
argentina and south africa for two
absolutely obviously
south korea is another example and the
philippines
[Music]
i think
we have to understand though that what
why would the united states do this is
it simply to keep somebody who is a
friend of the united states in power
success of presidents and it's not just
reagan and it's not carter before him
it's successive president since
basically since the 50s
since eisenhower have
been
working hand in glove and even have been
on camera embracing
successive dictators with whom we've
been identified
the most recent example if you remember
was the case of
of jimmy carter embracing the shah of
iran a few months before he was
overthrown
on the steps of the white house
i think
it's because of
the cia's
involvement and in fact direction of
much of these
activities
it's not that the cia is working
uh
on its own as some people suggest as a
rogue elephant
the cia works directly under the
under the
guidance and direction of the
chief of state of the president and of
course this president not only doesn't
know but doesn't want to know every day
what the cia is doing but the fact of
the matter is that they that they're
doing what the president asked them to
do
and the other thing i should just
mention quickly is that the
cia carries out these activities to keep
the interests of the corporations u.s
corporations who have
great interests at stake for example in
south africa and in all the other
countries we've mentioned that's right
the multinationals value stability above
everything else plus the ability to
operate there keep the economy low as
far as wages and be able to take the
riches out of the country and these
right-wing dictatorships let them do
that of course there's a point which is
reached that like in el salvador once it
gets too far and the people really start
not
a revolution then the multinationals
suffer there and there is a certain
level beyond which the u.s
when it becomes publicly known as
opposed to known in the country itself
publicly known in the united states that
the us is so closely identified with
such a repressive regime as today in el
salvador
that it finally realizes it has to fish
or cut bait it has to decide whether we
continue to support this openly or
whether we have to find other ways to
support as as for example argentina has
now offered we understand directly to
the united states to be a surrogate for
the u.s in in el salvador also honduras
is playing that role this is what's so
chilling about this agent's identities
information act that it will cover over
the possibility of the media exposing
the worst abuses
of the cia which will mean the american
people won't know what it's doing we'll
have a secret government and we will
therefore
increase the power and the scope of
operations of the cia
whereas in the past when there has been
media and public focus on cia operations
and excesses there has been pressure to
cut back
on the cia
i think however the most threatening
part of this is the is the whole
move towards greater and greater secrecy
and so that the media will not even have
the opportunity to report on this whole
area
it will be illegal almost for a
journalist for one of the major media
to write or to report
about intelligence in many ways that
will just be beyond the pale now
this also ties in with the progress of
senate bill 1
in the center of the great grand center
senate bill 1 which is designed to take
away a lot of our civil liberties
we're gradually becoming a police state
really looks like doesn't it well what
can be done about it
while i don't
feel it's
fair to
be rhetorical about this i agree that
there is a move and towards greater and
greater
secrecy and greater and greater
or less and less accountability of the
government to the people
and
there are of course a lot of people who
are
opposed to this including quite a few
members of congress
for example 29 members of congress
signed a resolution challenging the
right of the president to intervene in
el salvador under the war powers act
he has no
right to to do this and they're
challenging his right
uh and that's 29 members out of hundreds
but it is a significant i think
indication that there is even in the
halls of congress
opposition to his policies as well as in
the country at large i mean the
overwhelming majority are against
reagan's policy
in el salvador
and i think the
recent polls have shown that
the foreign policy in general is
not entirely accepted or is there is
great doubt and great
wonderment as to whether there's any
continuity whether the policy is thought
out whether it's based on realities or
only
the
very anti-communist rhetoric of this
administration
there are also quite a few
people
high in the administration who have
intelligence backgrounds and this is
another indication that the
that the
intelligence is on the on the rise in in
this administration lewis is the final
question and to conclude what can the
american people do
against these worst excesses of the cia
and indeed against the threats to all of
our civil liberties involved in some of
these bills that are being passed that
will unleash the cia
i think the biggest thing is that people
can educate themselves as to what is
going on to read their press
and to demand to know what is going on
from from the media
to
try and
exercise their rights that is to let
their congress their member of congress
know that they don't accept whatever the
policy may be
even to demonstrate uh publicly if
they're opposed to these activities i
think most of all is to be to keep
themselves informed and to speak out
against it
well thank you very much for and good
luck
and watch
watch your way home there may be
somebody following you
well i i believe it's best to uh to
speak out openly and uh
and not be paranoid i'm just i'm not
willing to resign myself to
fear
okay
thank you
and that is the second of our three-part
series on covert action the cia
and now we have a final word from doug
here's some of the antics that the moral
majority has been up to recently
the head of their maryland chapter jim
wright recently went to the ameri the
maryland state legislature and
complained about some bakery that was
selling gingerbread cookies of little
boys and little girls whose anatomy was
displayed in these cookies and
predictably the cookie source sale
soared after the moral majority attack
on these cookies and evidently the
legislators are still laughing in
maryland about that not quite as funny
is the head of the moral majority in new
york a reverend dan four was recently
caught with his foot in the mouth in an
interview with the new york times first
of all he told the times that the jews
have god given ability to make money
they control the media they control the
city when the jewish reporter who was
interviewing him mentioned that jews had
been subject to inquisitions throughout
the centuries and that the anti-semitism
the moral majority was feeding into this
he said that the head of the moral
majority said that well
there was never any christian
persecution of jews
and the
moral the reporter joe klein in the new
york times reminded him of the spanish
inquisition and his persecution of jews
here's what the moral majority said well
those weren't christians they were roman
catholics
strange distinction
and then last but not least the head of
the santa clara county chapter of the
moral majority opined to reporters that
capital punishment would be in line with
bible dictates and appropriate treatment
for
homosexuality
now it's true that the moral majority
has been criticized recently in the
media and it's also argued that the kiss
of death in a political election is
moral majority support we've seen two
elections recently in austin on housing
discrimination for in the school board
when the moral majority got heavily
involved in this and the opponents were
able to mobilize opposition to this
moral majority attempt to legislate its
morality and was able to defeat moral
majority initiatives moreover the moral
majority television programs are getting
more and more in debt and i read in
broadcasting that their viewing audience
has gone down about 16
now you would think that the moral
majority would be on the defensive and
in a retreat but in fact jerry falwell
is exploiting these attacks on the moral
majority to try to raise more money
every month he sends out a new
fundraising letter saying that they're
about to go bankrupt and that they will
be destroyed by their enemies unless you
dig into your pockets and send the moral
majorities to more money so there was a
result of this whereas last year they
were only able to raise two million
dollars they've already in the last 12
months been able to raise
5.7 million dollars and i've been
increasingly successful with these
crisis
campaigns to raise money and to play on
the sympathies of their supporters that
the moral majority is a beleaguered
oppositional group that's been attacked
by all these liberals and humanists etc
so we're far from having heard the last
of the moral majority unfortunately
this concludes the second in our
three-part series on covert action
featuring john stockwell former cia
official
and lewis wolf
of covert action information bulletin
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network po box
7279 austin texas
if 78712 like to write to us give us
some of your feedback
we'd really like to hear from you
please contact us at this address
goodnight
you